- The absolute worst
thing that could happen
as I'm wearing a skirt
is me flashing someone,
and my underwear and my penis not being
as aligned as they should be.
(upbeat music)
- I can't remember, but, honestly,
I probably did wear a
skirt when I was younger.
- I don't know, it seems that sometimes
pants are a little bit restricting.
I'm kinda excited to get
in there and get breezy.
- I don't really think that I have
a very sexy lower body.
So opening myself up like this,
it's gonna be quite interesting.
- My personal goal is to
become more confident with my body.
- I'm not sure about this color.
- This is very short.
I don't think this is what we discussed.
- I love blues, I love whites, perfect.
- I don't think anyone really
told me how hard it would
be to hide my penis.
- These things are not very functional.
I have to figure out other ways
to carry things around without pockets.
- Because you always sit like this, Edgar.
You can't do that in a skirt.
Look at him, look at him.
Improper form right there.
- I personally feel like I
look good in this outfit,
but I still feel
self-conscious wearing it.
- I think the hardest part about this
is I'm not sure if I'm matching.
I don't know if this shirt
goes with this skirt.
- It took me a while to be like,
oh, does he have a skirt
on his body right now?
It fits your look, you look good.
- I just go home from work,
and there was this family walking by,
and so I ran back into my car.
I mean, it's totally weird because,
just earlier today, I was outside
walking around in public,
wearing this skirt with friends,
and I was totally fine because I had them.
And it kind of is stupid that I can't
do this by myself.
- I'm not gonna lie, the
walks down the street
are getting a little hard.
I feel like I'm being stared at.
I mean, I know I'm wearing a skirt,
and that's why they're looking, but...
I guess I kinda underestimated
how much it will kind of affect me.
- It's interesting that, immediately,
if you're wearing something that
isn't considered your gender's norm,
that people get kinda weird about it.
- After the car incident,
my good friend Shane gave
me a little pep talk.
- Nobody cares that you're
wearing a skirt except for you.
- Life lessons.
- So it's been about a week now,
and, to be honest, I'm probably
gonna miss wearing a skirt.
It's just been a super great experience.
I really loved it.
- I was stopped on several
occasions and told,
"Dude, I can see your penis."
So, I wasn't good at that part.
- Getting used to now pockets was a thing,
so I ended up having to
carry a bag around with me.
It took a little getting used to,
but I had a lot of fun with
getting into my outfits.
Looking good.
- I am more in tune with my body,
and I am more confident,
and I don't really care as much
about what people think.
- No, I probably won't wear a skirt again.
It's cause I can't cross my legs.
That's the only reason why.
If I could cross my legs, I would do it,
but I cannot.
- I think guys can rock skirts.
I think anybody can rock anything,
and who's to tell you that you're not?
If you're confident in
what you're wearing,
and you feel comfortable in it,
then you are rocking it.